Many many years ago, Kate and I, my wife quit
our jobs and took 3 months off to essentially
be homeless traveling around the United States.
We stayed with friends, friends of friends used
national parks as sort of checkpoints throughout.
And we are in Sequoia National Park walking along
and I actually have this... There's a picture
of my wife. Well, this is actually a tree.
This is a picture of Kate and we're walking along
this unbelievable national park and we see a park
ranger. He's about 85 years old, big white
beard and he's got one of those flat-brimmed
like smokey the bear classic park ranger hats. And
as we're walking up to him, Kate looks over to him
and just says, "Hey, nice hat." And he immediately
takes off his hat and holds it out to Kate.
Now, I'll fill in the rest of the story
in a moment. But in the next 45 minutes
after this beginning of an interaction, we
learned one of the most powerful lessons in how to
create conversations that matter. And that
is what this video is going to focus on.
My partner Will Wise and I wrote a book called
Ask Powerful Questions where the subtitle is
How To Create Conversations That Matter.
And I'm excited to dive in in this video
with 4 particular tips and ideas that the
minute this video is done will ensure that
you have more meaningful impactful
conversations. Let's get into it.
Picking up the story where it left off, Frank,
we soon found out had took off his
hat and looked at Kate and said,
"Want to try it on?" Like that was his response.
Kate compliment his hat, immediately takes off his
hat, offers it to Kate, and offers to try it on.
Of course, she did. Of course, it looked amazing.
And you can give... Just from that little
moment, you can tell a little bit about who Frank
is on the planet. Now, Frank was an educator
for 40-plus years, had this unbelievable ability
to just make you feel comfortable and warm
and welcome and instantly a total stranger,
in this case, literally in the middle of the
woods, built rapport and created a conversation
that really mattered. And we actually
sat on a bench with him for 45 minutes
and he shared with us, Frank's one-million-dollar
lesson. And that's how he framed it. He said, "All
of my students, no matter what grade, no matter
what year I was teaching; I would always teach
them the million-dollar lesson. Would you like to
know it?" Like, "Yeah." And Frank wrote down, I
took a picture of this card. Since lost the card,
but I'm glad I took a picture of it. I wrote down
Frank's million-dollar lesson. This is Frank's
handwriting from Sequoia National Park and you can
see and unpack his ideas here real quick. So, just
verbally, look at the person who's talking. One
person talks at a time. Don't do anything but
listen and allow time for reflection. Now,
this is in the book Ask Powerful Questions. We
unpack this pyramid of skills, tools, and mindsets
to be able to create conversations that really
matter. And one of those levels is listening.
Without it, you don't have a conversation.
Without it, you have a bunch of people yelling
at a wall, right? And so, listening is not
only essential to a good conversation. And
most of us, and if you're watching this video,
you're probably familiar with the phrase active
listening. I'm not a huge fan of active
listening because it's so behavioral, right?
I can sit forward. And to be honest, I can look
at the person who's talking, I can nod my head. I
can check all the boxes that meet the criteria for
active listening. I would say that one of the most
important ingredients to conversations that matter
is careful listening. And in fact, even though
Frank gave us this million-dollar lesson in
this moment in the Sequoia National Forest,
Kate and I have continued to learn this lesson of
listening over and over and over again. And with
my clients, as I'm working with some of the top
universities and organizations on the planet,
I'm continuing to re-learn how impactful
listening is. If you've ever been in a meeting
and someone's repeating themselves over and over
again, it's because they don't feel heard, right?
And listening has the power to do that. In fact,
I would argue that the way that we listen actually
has the power to change what people say. Now fast
forward. This was many, many years ago that we met
Frank. Just a few nights ago, Kate and I, when
we are able to make the time like to do a like
a nightly reading before we go to bed or after
dinner or something. And there was a line in a
reading we did the other night that I thought
was so profound. I needed to share with the
world in this format. And it was "The truth is
that careful listening feels so much like love
that most of us can hardly tell the difference."
And I'm not saying that every conversation needs
to be loving, you're probably not watching this
video in the context of a romantic relationship.
And yet, if you want to know how to create
conversations that matter at a very deep level
and you may never use this word, love. But at a
very deep level, if the other person feels seen,
heard and like you want to seek understanding
from them rather than seeking to be understood,
careful listening communicates that louder
than anything you will ever be able to say,
louder than any perfect question you're able
to craft and send over. It makes a massive,
massive difference. Now, do the questions we ask
make a difference to the conversations that we
have? Yeah, absolutely. In fact, at the time of
recording this, we're in the midst of a bunch of
presidential debates in the united states.
And it's been driving me crazy listening to
some of the moderators in the way that they frame
questions. Now, not to make a comment on politics.
There's... I think lots of reasons the debates
have not been going super well. But in particular,
what I've noticed is that all of the questions
begin with why. Why are you better than you?
They're pitting each other against each other.
And so, one of the things that does invite better
listening typically in yourself and in others is
asking questions that begin with how or what and
not why. Because when we ask questions that begin
with why, we're asking for justification. If you
want to create conversations that matter, make 2
very simple adjustments. Edit the word that your
questions begin with to how or what rather than
why. Cut why questions out of your vocabulary. If
your aim is to create conversations that matter,
ask questions that begin with how or what and then
be like Frank. I'll hold these up one more time.
Look at the person who's talking. One person talks
at a time. Don't do anything but listen and allow
time for reflection. I think what Frank has mapped
out here is what the reading that Kate and I
read the other night also hit on. And I think
it is starting to point to some universal truth
that I don't think that i've even necessarily
mastered or figured out. But it is that careful
listening is far more impactful and meaningful
than active listening. And so, I like all
of my videos as much as possible to be
a conversation. So, I'd love to hear from you.
Let me know what you think in the comments.
Let me know who you are going to listen to more
deeply and have an awesome day. Happy listening.